and did you know the uh the Japanese zen
garden riyanji
uh it it's a very beautiful garden it
has 15 rocks set out in the in the sand
and from wherever you stand in the
garden the most you can ever see is 14
of them
okay so I love that
Nicholas acouza when he writes the
vision of God and he sends it to the
monastery he sends a painting
and no matter where you stand in the
room it looks like the painting is
looking at you and then he says first
everybody do that and then do the
following one monk stands in one place
and another Monk stands in the farthest
other place and they both claim that the
picture is looking at them and then he
says
go ahead no that's just true of any
painting where you exactly it's nothing
special it's just this phenomenally oh
yeah he's a following no they're not
it's just that wherever you look you
think the face is looking at you
so he
he he well I think that's the point uh
because then he says
now try to what would it be like to be
able to realize this all at once and of
course you can't but he says that's what
it is to have the vision of God it's not
to see God it's to see the way God sees
right it's to see that through line that
you can't actually see because it makes
all seeing possible Right
and so this is again the non-thingness
that is not privation but is the
inexhaustible found with which from
which intelligibility flows and flows
and I think for me that has been
that has been my fundamental
phenomenologically rich and reflective
experience of the Sacred to exactly find
that and for me Gerta is is talking
about that when he's looking at the
plants and I see the same thing with
when you're in the platonic dialogues
you have this Quest right to find the
virtue but you never get to the answer
but you get the through Line running and
all that sort of thing for me and like
you said that's when I find the sacred
in another person when I realize that
there's there's multi-aspected
multifaceted but there's a through line
and I can hear it and paste it and
follow it but I can never complete it or
grasp it totally and if I say that to
her I've destroyed the relationship so
that would be the most foolish thing to
do but as you said everything is like
that and that means we can fall in love
with being again it's not like for me
that that's a real possibility for
people
I'm sorry that that that's for me what I
I I think is if we could enable people
to read through a way of life to fall in
love with being again I think that would
be a deep way of responding to the main
crisis
certainly a rather nice way of
expressing it I agree and love is
probably going to be part of how one
achieves that
um
and you you touched on that idea of the
not just the way God sees but of the way
we see God and I'm trying to think who
it was now was it it
might have been
Bonaventure or somebody who said you
know the eye with which I see God
exactly yeah it's the same eye with
which God sees me exactly but anyway yes
that's a a good point but how on Earth
um are we to if if uh if the subject
we're talking about is how to bring this
about how do we how do we help bring it
about or perhaps that isn't the question
or perhaps it's not even a good question
well I think it's whether or not it's a
well-formed question or not I think it's
probative
um one of the books that's had the most
profound influence on me is religion and
nothingness by nishitani and he it's a
fall and it's a masterpiece and it's
rightly regarded so it's a follow-up to
his earlier book The self-overcoming of
nihilism and to give you a flavor of it
there's another quote very similar to
eckhart's which was uttered by Nietzsche
uh if you stare long enough into the
abyss it begins to stare back into you
Nietzsche Came Upon something but he
gets to the edge of it but he doesn't it
doesn't flip over for him and what uh
what Mr Taney proposes is
um
he proposes that
and I I'm interested because you might
have a really interesting take on
Nietzsche doesn't doubt deeply enough
it it's almost like the left hemisphere
is capable of this profound doubt but it
can never doubt its own authority or its
own preeminence or something like that
yeah so very much yes yes and and he
proposes like one that one of the
practice one of the points of Zen is to
get the great doubt that drops you
beneath and then that profound resonance
beliefs The propositional Tyranny gets
disclosed to people and I think I think
that's
part of what needs to happen right now
I'm not saying I'm not recommending Zed
I'm saying we have to get something in
which we
we we live in the hermeneutics of
Suspicion where we doubt everything
except we doubt the perspective The
Stance from which that happens and I've
been trying to figure out the semantic
philosophical Jujitsu moved right in
order to get that doubt to actually turn
onto itself in a profoundly
transformative way without of course
destroying people's sanity or lives of
putting them into a psychotic break or
anything ridiculous like that no of
course but one of the things that can
break us out of that doubting of
everything
um is the experience the Transcendent
experience of something very real and
it's yeah in a way that comes as part of
it's one of these self-referential
things that you can't break into in
unfortunately because you can't cause
this experience to happen to you but you
can put yourself in the way of it
happening yes which is included and what
worries me is that the way we live now
with our attention so fragmented and
ourselves so bound up in verbal noise
and discussion about you know all the
things we're talking about one of the
things that troubles me actually about
where this conversation is going is that
the wise person stops talking at this
point because really we're entering the
territory where you cannot talk about it
so
um but we drown out the possibility of
being there for
whatever you mean by the sacred even for
the beautiful because you need to attend
to it deeply not just sort of allow it
to be in the background somewhere you
actually have to
have an encounter with it and it's that
that changes changes one's one's way of
being
I suppose I agree with you and I I mean
I I do think what
there is an intermediary which is to try
and find people that are exemplifying
an encounter with the really real and
there's a there's a large proportion of
the population in which that even
happens spontaneously at least 30 at
least 30 percent perhaps 40. so we've
got a culture that silences them but it
doesn't have to be the way there's no
necessity for that no you're right
so for me it's beyond a trend it's
beyond a mystical experience it's a
transformative experience so
um uh it's an experience in which
one
has many of the features of a mystical
experience the Oneness the the the the
the the the
hereness the nowness the altogetherness
the depth of realness but it's
ultimately ineffable but it carries with
it
um
um all the markers of being
real such that people do the following
they will they'll do something weird
normally when we have an aberrant State
of Consciousness that doesn't fit into
our everyday Consciousness we use that
to say it's not real like a dream or
being drunk but they do the opposite
they cut they have these experiences and
they say that was really real and all of
this is an illusion
and they then they say I'm the must is
not
a compulsive must it's what I call
autonomativity that they I need I need I
profoundly need to change who I am and
how I relate to the world maybe my
occupation my career they will
profoundly change their lives because
they want to be closer to that really
real they want to conform more to it and
Jaden's work shows by many objective
measures
their lives get better uh that's what I
mean by uh a Transformer and uh Steve
Taylor has a book I think it's called
waking up where he taught the canvases
all of this it's not it's not it's not a
scientifically profound book but it's
great for just Gathering all these
accounts together now it's extraordinary
how commonly is experiences of um well
it even can be described as encounters
with God actually by a lot of people
even though they don't necessarily
believe in God at all but they call them
encounters with God or with the cosmos
with the ultimate truth or whatever it
is and they're surprisingly common
well and and they are not predicted by
any kind of mental disorder and neither
neither do they generate any kind of men
no yeah no no the very important point
you've already made which is that when
people have hallucinations and delusions
when they're better they count them as
unreal and they see that they're better
off without them but after these
experiences they don't they they think
this is the this was the reality and it
often has long-term uh changing effects
on their lives exactly as you say so
it's something that needs to be taken
seriously and there is research and some
of it you've probably been mentioning
which which shows how very real and
important this is so we discount this
um because we're told that clever people
bright people intelligent people don't
think like this it's just some
um ill effect of something misbehaving
in one's brain but it it's not an
adequate account yeah and I I go over
both I've given talks on this and
conferences I go over it in Awakening
for the meeting crisis on higher States
Of Consciousness I've talked about it at
Yale Etc you can make a very good case
for this is actually a justifiable claim
I mean well
um I don't hang too much on the
propositions they come back with because
the propositions vary all over the place
but that sense I've done an experiment
in my lab where we like what's the
relationship nobody did this which we
thought I thought was astonishing is
there a correlation between having
mystical experiences and how meaningful
you find your life you would have
thought somebody had bothered to test
that it shows you the ignorance of our
orientation that that has not never even
been tested we tested it a huge am
church study it is predictive it's Coral
it's correlative right and but it's not
the particular phenomenology
phenomological content it's the Insight
Machinery it's it's very much in a
continue think about when you have an
Insight right and you oh and then you
know why you were wrong before but you
can't know until you go through it right
it's it's that it's that kind of thing
it's like it's like a it's like a a
systemic yeah steak and a systematic
insight and what's interesting is that
the area in which we have aha moments
the right Superior temporal gyrus and
celticus is very close to the area that
has been repeatedly found to be
associated with transformative religious
experience exactly the right temporal
parietal Junction effectively so I mean
that's interesting at every level but I
feel Kurt you need to help us
reorientate because we're talking about
things that well I just want to I just
wanted to talk about I just wanted to
follow up though because right if we
agree that this is a real phenomena and
if we agree that it's not hallucinatory
or something that we can dismiss then
like and then if we could also find you
know first of all if we can support that
culturally and also watch people
unfolding exemplary lives this is sort
of the socratic proposal don't you know
you know you know here's a beautiful
life
right the unexamined life is not worth
living here's a here's a beautiful life
and I think that's the kind of thing
that can attract people into what we're
talking about I I agree we can't we
can't give them here's how you do it but
what we can do we can we can cultivate
cultivate the people who are living
exemplary lives and create you know
communities where they Thrive that
attract people I propose we could do
that I I agree in in a way you've you've
given a description of what I aim to do
in my work which is to take people where
they see this is a beautiful vision of
life and it makes much more sense you
just watched a clip from the theories of
everything channel for the full video
and all its magnificence then click here
and if you'd like to see more then
subscribe enjoy